It is time for Drew's News!
Your daily sniff of the good news scented candle.
I need a good news candle.
You want some good news?
That's Ross Mathews,
he's the best news.
Yeah, yes!
(audience cheering)
Oh, thanks.
You gotta spread the good around a little bit.
That's what we do here at the desk, right, Drew?
Spread it.
Spread it, get in there.
Let's get to the news.
First up, we've got wedding bells
for the Barker-Kardashians.
Oh!
That's right.
It literally just happened.
I love this.
Or did it?
"The Cut" reports, after the Grammys in Vegas last weekend,
Kourtney Kardashian and Travis Barker
hit the chapel, as one does in Vegas, come on.
At 1:30 in the morning, the love birds got married
by an Elvis impersonator in true chef's kiss Vegas style.
But there is rumor that maybe it's not official,
and it was sort of a practice fun ceremony.
I don't know, maybe we'll find out on their show.
I don't know what this is.
But I think congratulations to the happy couple.
It sounds like a really fun night.
Of course, I'm like, "Did they do it for the show?
Is this not real or is it real?"
I don't know.
I hope it's real.
I hope so bad it's real,
'cause I like them together as a couple.
And I will say the Kardashians, and this is no shade,
but they have had some outlandish weddings
in the past, right?
We've all watched it.
And so the fact that they maybe
did this like little intimate thing, I think is cute.
And the reports were, it was just the two of them.
But I think they probably filmed it
on their iPhone, right,
for the Hulu show?
Well.
They have to, like contractually, wouldn't you think?
Kourtney Kardashian has texted
like something about a fun night, tequila, no license.
Oh really?
She just put this out on social?
Yes.
So the report now is they did it,
but there was no official license.
No receipts.
So that's the legit means it didn't happen then.
Yep, I guess so.
Or it's not official at least, all right.
Well, fun night though.
Totally.
And I feel like they kind of give me
all the friskies, you know?
Yeah.
And so I like them
and we need a little more friskiness in our lives.
Exactly, bring it on!
And thank you to Travis.
Bring on, so good luck to them,
whatever the case may be.
Drew, you're up.
All right, flamingo alert!
"People" reports a flamingo was spotted in Texas.
That's right, fisherman David Foreman
caught the bird on camera.
And it turns out that this is flamingo number 492,
a bird that's been on the run since 2005
when it escaped a Kansas zoo.
Wow.
Apparently, he has been living his best life
in coastal Texas.
People have spotted him over the years,
affectionately nicknaming him, Pink Floyd.
Oh.
And the good news is 'cause, of course, I had to ask,
he still remains free.
Yeah.
Where will he go next?
I don't know, but like now I feel like
whenever I'm gonna have a day off in life,
it's gonna be a 492.
Yeah.
You're just gonna flamin-go, girl.
I am.
And they put the anklet on,
it came to the Kansas zoo when it was a baby,
but they didn't get to clip its wings.
They didn't have time before they took off.
And I think it's a great metaphor,
don't clip the wings.
Yeah, flamingos always freak me out a little bit.
Why?
Because they stand
on one leg and they hide their head in the sand.
Like what are you hiding, girl?
What are you hiding?
I don't trust you.
So does that go for ostriches too?
Yeah, I don't trust them either.
I don't, I don't.
Well, from pink to green news,
we've got a little bit of green news for you.
Oh, good transition.
(audience clapping)
"The New York Times" reports,
you know those little plastic six-pack rings
that are on like beer cans or soda?
Uh-huh.
Well, say bu-bye to them,
'cause they're gonna be history.
Really?
Yeah.
Coors Light is the latest mega beer brand to get rid of 'em.
By 2025, they say they're gonna use all cardboard rings
eliminating 1.7 million pounds of plastic per year.
And we've all heard those stories
about those rings in the ocean.
So goodbye, goodbye.
Isn't that great news?
Thank you!
(upbeat music)